Context: I recently uploaded a video
that was ten minutes long
and consisted of me doing
nothing but eating cereal.
Yes. If you haven't seen it yet, don't worry.
It's really not vital viewing.
Most people haven't watched it.
Most people that clicked to watch
the video still haven't seen it yet,
and the reason that this video exists is
because someone left me a comment saying,
"Charlie you could literally eat
cereal for ten minutes
and I would find it entertaining."
And I saw that and I thought, "No you wouldn't,
and I'm gonna prove it to you."
However, what I wasn't expecting was
that, although most people, yeah,
thought it was boring, a large number
of people left comments saying
that they did watch and enjoy the
whole video, and it confused me.
It peaked my curiosity.
At this point, I decided to
compare the like/dislike ratio
of the ten minute video of me eating cereal,
which took me a morning to make,
with my ten minute short film,
"The Tea Chronicles,"
which took me many, many months
and a substantial amount of money to make,
and it turned out people did
like my short film more, yay,
but only 16% more,
which did leave me wondering,
"Was it worth putting in all
of that extra effort?"
My instinct has always told me that
the more effort you put into something,
the more inherent worth
that thing must have,
but I am starting to wonder
if that is actually true.
Take Pewdiepie, for example. He is someone
who a lot of people don't like
because he is incredibly successful,
so incredibly successful,
for doing something that
seems very easy.
He talks while playing
video games.
That's not hard, right?
However, what I hadn't thought about
before is that even if his videos, objectively,
take less time and effort to put together
than a sketch or a short film or an animation
why does that mean that what he does
is less worth while because, clearly,
millions of people love
what of he does
and I feel like that should
be worth something.
With my cereal video, even though
I tried to put a bit of effort into it
like I tried to light it
and frame it nicely
and I added background music
throughout the whole thing,
I made it and I still
think it's rubbish,
but when I see something like a Tumblr
that is dedicated just to videos
of other people eating
breakfast with me remotely,
clearly, someone is getting
something out of what I made.
I think it's fair to say, as well,
that some of the people who hold that
"This Didn't Take As Much Time To Make
And Therefore It Is Not As Worth While" Attitude
think that about video blogging,
and I can completely sympathize
with that point of view as well,
given that a large amount of video bloggers
do seem to make just "content."
They will make videos about vapid topics
that don't feel like they have any worth.
But what confuses me
about that is the idea
that you would write off
all of vlogging just
because some people don't use
the medium in a way that you like.
To me, that is the same as
like writing off all of music
because you do not
like pop songs.
The most popular video that I've ever
made was me trying to do an
American accent and failing.
And did it because I was busy that week and
I couldn't think of anything else to do.
It was a filler video.
But what I deem to be my most successful
video is not the one with the most views
or even the one with like the
highest production value.
It's the one that allowed me to
make the strongest connection
with the people who did watch it, in this case,
an insane amount of video responses.
But, when it comes to which
video has more worth,
I feel like you could make a
strong argument either way.
Like, I prefer "I'm Scared," but I know a lot
of people wouldn't have found me
and seen that video if it hadn't
been for "My American Accent,"
so I don't know.
I don't know when it happened,
but, at some point,
someone at YouTube decided that they
were going to call us all "content creators,"
which is the blandest title that I think
we all could possibly have hoped for.
Frankly, I don't want to
be making "content"
'cause that sounds to me like something
you're doing just to fill in a gap.
On the flip side, I don't feel like I would
ever be comfortable calling what I do "art."
I can't get over how
pretentious that sounds,
but I what I do worry is
that, as YouTubers,
we maybe undervalue
what we do.
Most of the time, we are
just making stuff in the hopes
that it'll make someone
else laugh and that is it.
We're not looking for a
deep connection,
but I do genuinely think
that, as YouTubers,
we have the ability to make
stuff like nobody else can,
and I think that
people like us for it,
and, surely, that is
worth something.
Anyway, that's what I've been
thinking about recently.
Let me know what you think,
and I'll see you later. Bye!
STEPHEN FRY VOICE: You've just had the almost
imponderable joy of watching charlieissocoollike,
which makes you, like, cool.
CLAP
BURP
And the vlog has begun.
Always tempted to
put the burps in.
Let's see if I can avoid
putting in that one.